that's
such a different gear yeah just get it
over with
that i'm trying to get it so that it'll
lock the tilt two two
clicks activates tilt regardless so if i
hit it just once
perfect okay so just hitting it once
locks tilt two unlocks
then three flips it
dude this is like something i always
wanted to do was basically shoot a video
on a gimbal while right right in the one
wheel this setup
is an infinite dolly i can dolly all
kinds of really cool shots like forever
so imagine some sort of like chasing or
imagine yeah
just like any sort of scene that
requires a lot of motion but intricate
paths like you can't just ride in a car
down
you know a side street but bikes and
stuff can go there
but it's hard to like ride a bike
one-handed while trying to film
it was on a one-wheel your hands are
completely free that's all you gotta do
is just think about moving and you move
let's be real if you have an iphone or
an android phone within the last year or
two
you have an excellent camera why buy
another camera when you can just use
your phone
and if you want to get those sweet
gimbal shots like basically what we did
for real gta
we had a gopro and a gimbal great video
that would have worked just fine with a
phone and a gimbal you can buy a monopod
and attach it to the bottom of this so
you can have like a big pole if you want
what supposedly we have an adapter
really so you can sweet dude
obviously as you can imagine the rock's
a very busy guy uh considering he's the
most popular slash highest paid actor
in the world he doesn't have a lot of
free time we're trying to think all
right what do we do
with him that fits into like 30 minutes
let's say we have 30 minutes with him
what's the most we can do he's basically
doing kind of like a
fake kind of testimonial last just last
week he finished typing up our little
script we sent it over
it's approved now that's
the easy part so he's gonna come to set
and you're gonna have 30 minutes to
shoot
no we have to come to him
this is the most absurd thing aj
this is the gimbal attached to just a
what is this just to say k-tech boom
pole
with a little mount so it can actually
attach to the
got it got it look at this stabilized
video from like 20 feet away
you recommend getting all of our shots
yeah yeah
i also recommend not using a camera with
a broken lens like carmichael here
geez you're going to break that boom
hole dude no let's not break our
equipment
who's carbon fiber dude
you kidding me carbon fiber can break no
carbon fiber has no
possible way to break its science
carbon fiber can't break it's science
that is not true
carbon no carbon fiber is not a magic
material
carbon fiber is really stiff and strong
until it cracks and then it becomes
really weak
dude this is an expensive boom pole
let's not listen let me not break it
right spacex proved that carbon fiber
can't break
wait niko's coming and then we boom down
hi how's it going wait the lens is
cracked
you let me punch it and pretend the
impact is so hard you got a problem
we have to go to where he is and the
thing is
okay so he like calabasas he is
not going to be in california in fact he
is going to be in new york city
doing other promotional things for other
movies that he's doing
i'm going to go by myself like totally
by yourself
i think there's going to be one other
person there who's worked with the rock
before
no this is just some person who's worked
with him once or twice but
the rock himself he comes with a whole
team of people
when you make that much money and you're
that busy you
you need an entourage of people like
security teams
and like a producer and like etc
the script that we sent was super weird
and i'm like now that we're actually
doing it like
you're gonna go to new york meet him on
a stage then with likes and like
and you're just gonna shoot no okay so
we're gonna
see let's see this i know it keeps
unfolding it's like one of those like
it's like about those russian dolls it's
like a jank flower just yeah it's a
janky flower that keeps blossoming and
you see these janky petals that keep
unveiling themselves
i basically what i have at my disposal
is a hotel room
you know what the lightest strongest
material on earth is lightest and
strongest
carbon fiber
actually it's adamantium guys what
what's our
fictional strong metal
[Music]
i went into the bathroom and it was dark
and then i got in there and i was like i
know the switch is in here and i
couldn't remember where it was
so then i took out my phone to turn on
the flashlight to find the switch
but then what i forgot as i did that
there's a giant
wall mirror on that side so i went like
that and immediately saw another person
hiding in the dark
why are you still against it i'm not i'm
against misinformation
i think you're against carbon fiber
we're taking some carbon fiber bones
weight no bone weight bones are heavy
and carbon fiber is light as a feather
um i'm gonna have that i'm gonna have
one person to help
and then i like are they
gonna do the camera i'm just gonna go
into our camera room and i'm gonna grab
everything i need
so it's like the jankiest shoot ever for
the most non-janky actor ever
yeah exactly the least janky show that
we've ever made
yeah so i'm i'm really nervous mostly
just because it's
it's a very intimidating person to meet
i don't know if i'll be able to handle
it or just if i'll just shut down when i
meet him
and really really my the fear is is the
fact that
we we wrote the script with the
intention of like trying to make the
weirdest thing
possible with him like
hi everyone it's me poppy
i've been thinking a lot about what i
said but the point is that everyone will
be forced to watch it because the rock
is in it yeah
i want to take this moment to apologize
like that kind of stuff that's weird
right probably is weird
you haven't seen poppy stuff oh well
basically
what i said may have been hurtful to
some people
i know i've been watching poppy for like
the last few months and it's kind of
taken over my life
oh and that's it's not it's not like a
ripoff but like it's the creepy it's the
creepy
super hyper present microphone stuff oh
my god
we're going to pull that off with him
one note he's he's like
freaking out and like shaking and then
it just hard cuts and he's like super
calm and like
you know like because of life
one last funny kicker i'm gonna fly out
probably on wednesday or thursday
and i'm not gonna know when that half
hour time slot
is until like potentially the morning of
so i'm gonna have to fly there and
basically be on call for like two or
three days
waiting for to like know in advance when
the shoot's gonna happen
so it's not really gonna be much of a
trip it's gonna be me going and sitting
in a hotel room for like two or three
days
and then randomly getting a phone call
saying oh it's happening
i'm like oh wow can you please bring a
gopro with you yeah yeah
yes yes i'm going to i'm excited for you
thanks
saying it louder doesn't really make
anything happen
changing two chain one
ginger none
none
and what makes carbon fiber great is it
has a very strength to weight ratio
until it cracks then it loses all its
strength and integrity
on the back it'll say it's the most
strong of all things
and the strength ratio i hate you so
much right now
it's like it's
it's mostly true it's mostly true but
there's a big asterisk that you're just
like
wiping aside
i come in today with my mindset all i'm
doing one thing and now it's complete
180 we're doing something else not only
are we doing something completely
different we have to do it
in a really really short amount of time
we need to be cool we need to be
special jake pitched audible on this
shadow idea
which i don't think he really had an
idea so we're shooting on wednesday
which is two days from now in like a day
or two for shooting
day or two of editing and then a week of
effects and we chose an effects heavy
video
would you be shooting this no because i
have three videos to make this week
so who would shoot it